Laporalización es lo que pasa allí.
anti PT ah ¿cómo quiere una persona qué en
2007 un bono de protesta al que nos adherimos
La carne en Brasil es que tiene un perfume en el
situaciones muy complejas lado derecho
El encanto en Brasilia empezó con la victoria
puntos eran 300 Bolsonaro era de ella
parte de la política de Lula en La Paz.
texto muy interesante
separado del PT cuando una sílaba
presidente
eso cuando crecí allí, ¿verdad?
La protesta está diciendo en esta posición que hay.
allá adentro
en otras Petrolina Petrobras hay
regar con aceite allí en Brasilia es
que bolsonaro conseguir
posicionarse como allí para la habitación más
Es importante oponerse al PT.
preguntas Entonces impresión de Laura PT
cuando una posición más progresista de
Lazo aduanero separa a Bolsonaro del país
esto es asiduo a través de la zona más pivote de
todo suyo
ok momento